Welcome to this crash course on
best scripting. Throughout this
course Herbert will teach you a
wide range of topics, including
basic commands, writing your
first bash script, working with
variables, mastering control
structures, and diving into
powerful text manipulation tools
like awk and sed, Get ready to
unlock the full potential of
bash scripting and enhance your
productivity by automating
tasks, streamlining processes,
and making your workflow more
efficient. Hello, everyone, and
welcome to this introduction
course to bash shell scripting.
This course is aimed at anyone
who is new to shell scripting
people who want to expand their
knowledge or for those who want
to refresh their knowledge. My
name is Herbert and I will be
your instructor for this course.
I've been in the IT sector as a
system engineer since 2009. I've
dealt with multiple systems
ranging from Windows Server to
Linux servers, and in the last
few years, I started
specializing in automation and
development. I've been doing
YouTube content creation since
2017. Up until now, and I've
already created a course on
Linux, which might be a good
starting point. If you're
completely new to Linux, I want
to learn more about the basics
of the operating system itself.
Now what is bash, bash is short
for Bourne again, shell, it
replaced the Bourne shell in the
glue slash Linux project, which
was the default shell for Unix
operating systems. A shell is a
user interface for ease of use,
it makes it easy for the user to
manage the operating system
without knowing all of the inner
workings and complexity of the
operating system itself.
Now why would you learn bash?
Well, the reason you want to
learn Bash is because it's
currently the most popular shell
scripting language for the Linux
operating system. Bash has been
around forever it has been used
since the early days of Linux,
and it has stood the test of
time ever since. It's also
included in Mac OS and in
windows when you're using the
Windows subsystem for Linux.
Now, why would you not use bash?
Well, even though Bash is
considered a programming
language, it obviously lacks
some features. For example, the
ability to do object oriented
programming is not available in
bash. Python would obviously be
the preferred choice here if
you're looking to create more
advanced scripts that allow
object oriented programming.
Speaking of Python, bash is also
more complex in its syntax. When
comparing Python syntax to bash
one could say that Bash is a lot
harder to read and write. Not
only Python is often a better
choice for more advanced
scripting. Newer tools like
Ansible also make it a lot
easier for you to manage
multiple systems, which is a lot
harder to do with bash. Of
course, Ansible in Python are
often overkill for simple
scripts and using one does not
exclude the other. Bash is often
used in tandem with tools like
Ansible, or integrated in Python
scripts. This is exactly the
reason why you should learn
bash, just knowing the basics
could mean a big difference in a
lot of situations. Sometimes,
the old trusty tools are still
the most valuable. What will you
need for this course, I aimed
this course at the standard
Windows user. So I built the
course around the windows
subsystem for Linux, aka WsL.
Since we will be only using
command line tools and no GUI
WsL seems like the obvious
choice. And I also have a video
explaining how to install WsL on
Windows. If you're running a
true Linux distro, even better.
If you're using a Mac, you can
follow along in your terminal
window. But first make sure that
you have bash set as your
preferred shell. small
disclaimer basic Linux knowledge
is required. If you're
completely new to Linux, or even
new to bash, I would suggest you
at least follow along with the
Linux guide that I have on my
channel is going to give you a
good basic understanding of how
the Linux operating system
works.
Before we start with actual
scripting, let's first do some
basic commands in the terminal.
Let's look at an example of two
very simple commands to display
text in the command line. The
first one is called Echo, which
will display the text you pass
it as an argument. We will write
the command echo and then we
pass it some text like so we
just type in Echo Hello. And so
we can detect this by looking at
Echo as the command and hello as
the argument. We will learn more
about arguments later in this
course. In this case, we talk
about a positional argument.
Now we can see the output that
says hello, which is the word we
gave it as an argument.
Let's try and see how another
command the cat command compares
to this. The cat command
displays the contents of a file.
But right now we don't have one.
So let's first create a file
with our text editor Vim. In
this course, we're always going
to be using vim because it's a
good text editor that comes with
almost all Linux distributions.
Plus, it's actually not that
hard to use if you get the hang
of it. I myself have written
multiple scripts in bash.
In Python, with Vim, so it's
definitely a good text editor
unless you want to start writing
some serious scripts or
software. In that case, a decent
GUI text editor like VS code,
atom, or Sublime, or better
options.
Let's create a new file with
them by typing vim text file.
txt, and let's write something
in it. To write something in
Vim, press the I button, and you
will enter the insert mode.
From this mode, you can start
writing text. Let's write hello
world in this file, now we press
the Escape button. And you will
see that the insert mode is now
gone, we have exited the insert
mode and we're back into command
mode. And once you're back into
the regular command mode, you
can press the colon W to write
the file. And this will make
sure the changes we made are
actually done and saved to the
disk. And then we can press Q to
exit the file. Also, to make
life simpler, we can go into
Vim, make some changes and
combine the colon W and call on
Q to write colon wq. This will
automatically write the file and
quit vim at the same time.
If you made any changes you
don't want to save, you can
ignore the changes by typing
colon Q, exclamation mark, which
will quit vim while ignoring any
changes made.
Now that we created our file,
let's try to print the contents
of the file with the cat
command. This command will print
out whatever's in the first
positional argument, in our case
is the name of the file we just
created. So we just type in cat
txt file a TXT, and we should
see the contents of the file
printed here. Okay, great. We
can now print our own text and
also text files to the terminal.
This may not sound like much,
but it's something that you will
use a lot when writing bash
scripts.
So now finally, we are going to
write a shell script with the
knowledge we just gathered in
the previous section. Start off
by first opening your favorite
text editor, and named the text
file shell test.sh, like so. Vim
space, shell test.sh.
Now that we have our text editor
opened, let's try another mode
of writing text in Vim, the
Append mode, instead of pressing
i On your keyboard, press the A
button. This will append your
text rather than inserted. With
the insert mode, you write the
character before the cursor with
the Append mode, you write the
character after the cursor. Now
in this case, it doesn't matter
of course, because it's a new
file, but I thought I would
mention it anyways, since
sometimes it can come in handy.
Let's not start with our shell
script. In Vim, write echo Hello
World, and write and quit the
file by pressing the insert or
append mode, writing echo Hello
World, and pressing the Escape
button and then writing colon
wq. Now let's see if we can
actually find the file in here
using the ls command, which will
list all the files in our
current directory. As you can
see, the file is there and we
can verify the location by
looking at the terminals current
location over here, which says
the tilde symbol and the tilde
symbol indicates that we are in
our current home directory. By
typing P WD. We can verify that
we are indeed in the home
directory. pwd stands for print
working directory. And this way
we can print the directory that
we are currently working in,
which is indeed our home
directory.
Now let's run our file by
providing the command line with
the command line interpreter.
Which is bash space, shell
test.sh. This will output the
command we entered in the shell
script using the bash
interpreter. But when we type in
Echo dollar sign shell, we can
verify that we are actually
running in a bash shell. So
should we really have to specify
it? Well, the short answer is
yes. Just because we are running
in a bash shell, that does not
mean that Linux is going to
assume every file we want to run
is also in bash. We should
always provide an interpreter
for our shell scripts to use the
correct type of shell.
That does not mean however, that
we shouldn't make it easier for
ourselves. We can actually
provide the command line
interpreter in the shell script
itself by typing it at the top
of our script. In our case, we
have to provide the full path to
the shell interpreter. Let's
copy our output from the echo
dollar sign shell command and
use it in our shell script.
Copy the output by selecting it
and using either Ctrl C or right
clicking the selection either it
should work.
Now let's go back into our shell
script and let's enter the
insert mode. Since we want to
enter all this information in
the beginning of the file, press
I am type in pound sign
exclamation mark and then paste
in the output of the echo
Dollar Sign shell command. And
what we do here is we provide
the shebang. So the pound sign
exclamation mark is a way of
telling the shell script which
interpreter to use, we follow up
the shebang by providing the
full path to the shell
interpreter. And this way, the
shell knows which type of shell
interpreter it needs to use, we
can now run this file doing
period forward slash shell
test.sh. But we will see that
permission is denied and we need
to give the file permission to
be executed. This is because in
Linux, we need to give files
permission to act as an
executable file. Let's have a
look at this when we type in LS
minus l, which is a long format
of the ls command, which is
another type of argument we call
a flag. So the minus L here is
called a flag we give as an
argument to the ls command,
we're actually asking the ls
command to provide the long
format, which will display some
more information about the files
and directories, we can see in
our permissions that we do not
have executable permissions yet,
if you want to learn more about
the basics of file permissions,
you should look at my Linux for
beginners tutorial.
Let's give our file executable
permissions by typing in ch, mo
D or smart u plus x space shell
test.sh. We want to provide u
plus x because this will give
only the owner user permission
to execute the file rather than
the entire group or anybody on
the system.
It's good to have this
discipline baked into your head,
although on a development
environment, it doesn't really
matter very much.
Okay, now we can finally run our
shell script by typing in period
forward slash shell test.sh. And
we will see the output on the
terminal. Now that we finally
have the basics out of the way,
we can actually start writing
some bash scripts.
To understand a little bit
better what variables do in
bash, have a look at this
script. So in this script, you
have a classic example of a copy
command where we copy something
from to a location underneath
that we have the same location
paths twice typed out
completely. Now, this is
something that you want to avoid
as much as you can. Underneath
that we have a better option
where we actually define a
location path in a variable
called my location from now this
is quite a long variable name,
you could actually just define
something like loc underscore
from, which would be better
to make it a little bit shorter.
But it's just you know, it's
just for demonstration purposes
how this would work. So you
could understand if you would
have a very long path here, we
could have that very long file
location stored in a variable.
And then you could actually
reuse that variable over and
over again, like we did in the
example below with that. So
let's now have a look at how we
can actually use this in an
example. So we can either type
our name like this first name
equals, let's say Herbert. And
that's how we can actually use
these variables by typing like
Echo Hello, and then typing the
variable like so. So that's how
it would work like in line or in
the command line itself. But we
could actually also just write a
script to demonstrate a little
bit better how variables work.
So just type in Vim, hello,
there.sh.
And then we'll do the insert
mode with the shebang forward
slash bin forward slash bash.
And then over here, we'll define
our first name equals pervert or
you know your name. And then
last name, equals lindemans,
which is my last name. And that
will just do like this echo.
Hello, dollar sign first name.
And then we'll do dollar sign
last name.
And then we'll exits with wq.
And now, the only thing we need
to do is Srimad u plus x. Hello
there.sh. And now we can run it.
And now we can see that our name
is printed out here. Just like
that.
So now we actually type this
statically. But we can actually
also ask the user for input,
like so. So let's open a new
shell script with Vim.
Interactive shell.sh will do the
same insert, they'll do the
shebang bin bash. And first of
all, we'll need to ask the user
like, What is your name? So what
is your name? What is your first
name? Let's ask. And then we'll
do a read statement. I will read
the first name. I will do the
same with what is your last name
and I will read last name and I
will echo Hello
Oh,
dollar sign first name,
space dollar sign last name.
And then we'll write and quit.
And then we'll do the classic
smart u plus x. And then
interactive shell.sh. I will run
it and now it's going to prompt
us for our first name, or last
name, and then it will just
print out our first and last
name back. So
we could have the terminal
display our own name, or
anything else provided in a
positional argument as well. But
first, what is a positional
argument? A positional argument
is exactly what it sounds like,
we place the argument at a
certain position behind the
command or script we want to
run. The positional argument can
be in position, 123, and so
forth. The positions are always
separated by a space. When
working with positional
arguments, you expect arguments
to be in a certain position that
is separated by a space and
counting from one position zero
is reserved for the shell
itself.
Now let's have a look at one of
these positional arguments.
Create a new script by typing
vim pulse ru.sh. And enter the
insert mode again, we will have
the script taking our first and
last name and position one and
two and have it take these words
as positional arguments. Let's
just write our shebang and write
our one line of code like so.
shebang, Bin bash, Echo, hello.
Dollar sign $1 sign two. Now
save the file and close Vim,
change our permissions. And
let's run the script again with
the positional arguments dot
forward slash POS argue that sh,
herbert lindemans, or whatever
your name is here. And as you
can see, we get the same output
here with only one line of code.
One of the most frequently used
features in Bash is piping, it
makes it very easy to perform a
specific action on the output of
the command. Let's say the
output of a command is very long
and you wish to filter something
out. Piping is going to give you
that option. Now how does piping
work? Let's have a look at an
example.
Let's say we want to look at a
specific directory. But we just
want to filter out certain files
or subdirectories. We could for
example, use a command like
this. So we type in LS minus L
forward slash our directory. In
this case, we're using the bin
directory at forward slash user
forward slash bin and then space
and then we type the piping
symbol SPACE grep, which is
something that we use to filter
out specific words and then we
type in bash. And we'll see the
output is just the bash binaries
that we can see here. Rather
than the entire bin directory.
In this command, we forward the
output of the ls command into
the next command with the pipe
symbol. This symbol represents a
pipe and this is what we call
piping. We literally sent the
output from a command before the
pipe symbol to the command
behind the pipe symbol. grep is
just an example there are many
more commands that have very
powerful potential when used
with piping.
When sending output to a file,
we have to use different kinds
of symbols than the pipe symbol.
Instead, we use the greater than
and double greater than symbols.
These symbols will be used to
send the output from a command
to a file. This can have many
potential use cases, the first
thing that comes to mind is
logging something from your
script to a log file. And this
is something that you'll
definitely use in real life
scenarios. Let's see how we can
use these symbols. First, we
catch the output of a simple
echo command. Start by typing in
Echo hello world greater than
hello dot exe. This prints hello
world into a file called hello
dot txt. Notice that we put the
command before the greater than
symbol and the name of the text
file after the greater than
symbol. Now we can see if this
work by typing in cat hello dot
txt and we should see the output
of the echo command in here. Now
let's try something different
here typing echo Good day to
you. Greater than hello dot txt.
And let's see what's the hello
dot txt file by typing in cat
hello dot txt. But what is this,
the file was overwritten. We
don't have our hello world
anymore. This is because the
greater than symbol always
overwrites any existing file.
What we need to have is a proper
way to append text rather than
overwrite it. This is where the
double greater than symbol comes
in. This will append any output
to our destination file rather
than overwrite it. Let's try it
out. But first let's remove that
original file with RM space
hello dot txt. Then we use Echo
hello world double greater than
symbol hello dot txt
We check if the contents are
indeed correct with cat hello
dot exe. And indeed, the text is
there. And once we verified
this, we sent another output to
the file using the double
greater than symbol and type in
Echo Good day to you double
greater than hello dot exe. And
we once again verify this output
with cat hello dot exe. And we
should see both outputs here.
Now imagine using this in
combination with timestamps to
see which command ran at which
time and also some error
handling. We're starting to
collect the tools we need to
write real script, we can also
feed input into a command by
reversing the greater than
symbol, we can use the lesser
than double lesser than or even
triple lesser than symbol to get
input from a file, multiple
lines of text or a single string
of text. Let's first look at the
lesser than operator, which will
get input from a txt file. We
will use the word count command
as an example here, because it's
one of those commands that has a
use case for these types of
operators. Let's type in WC
minus w hello dot exe to get the
word count. But what happens
here, we get a little more than
we asked for as an output. The
wc command, by default also
shows the filename, which is not
what we want. If we just want to
get the number of words, we need
to feed the wc command and input
from the file with the lesser
than operator rather than the
file itself as a positional
argument. This can be done like
so WC minus w space lesser than
space hello dot txt, and this
way, we will redirect the file
to the wc command. Rather than
passing it as a positional
argument to the command, we will
now get to the second way of
feeding data to a command with
the double lesser than operator.
This is a great way to supply
multiple lines of text to a
command. When we write the
double lesser than operator, we
will immediately follow it up
with a word that will open and
close the text we want to input.
Basically, we tell the command
line Hey, wait for this word,
and then capture everything I
wrote in between the first and
second occurrence. Often people
will write e o f, but you can
write whatever you want. Let's
have a look at how this would
work. So we type in cat space,
double lesser than symbol elf.
Now we see that the command line
waits for input. So we can keep
writing lines of text here. And
let's write some text creating a
new line with the enter key
we'll type in I will enter write
some enter text here, enter. And
now we close it with the first
word we supply it and we type
again e o f. And now we should
see the text that we wrote here
between the two e o f
statements. Now last but not
least, we can also supply single
strings of text to the command
line. This will be done with you
guessed it the triple lesser
than operator. Let's have a look
at another example of the wc
command we use. By default, wc
will either read a file or a
command output, but not actual
strings supplied as positional
arguments. We should feed the
command either an entire file or
the output of a file with one of
the lesser than operator
variations. Let's see how we can
provide a string to this wc
command. So we typing w c minus
w again, space, triple lesser
than symbol, and then we open
with double quotes Hello, their
word count. And then we close
again with double quotes and we
should see the word count
printed here in the terminal.
This is how we can feed a string
into a command and take note
that the string needs to be in
between double quotes otherwise
it will not work.
In bash, we have a built in
command called test that will
take in a couple of arguments
and show you if the expression
is true or not. For example, we
can ask a terminal to show us
whether or not a string of text
is equal to another. We can
write test followed by the
expression, but I prefer using
square brackets. Let's see how
that's done. So we just write
open square brackets space. And
this is important because you
need the space in between Hello
space, equal sign space again
Hello, followed by another space
and enclosing the square
brackets. And this will show no
output but when we do echo
dollar sign question mark. We
should see output zero here
because the first string of text
is equal to the second and that
will give us a return value of
$0 sign question mark returns
the value of the exit code or
the last executed command. We
will learn more about exit codes
later. For now it's enough to
know that exit code zero means
that the command was executed
without any issues. Another
example of this would be
comparing numbers with each
other. For example, again
We open the square brackets
space one equals zero space, we
close the square brackets, and
then we do echo dollar sign
question mark. And this shows us
that the values are not the same
because we get a return code
one. But we could also use a
different operator here to make
sure that the values are
actually numerical. We could use
the minus EQ operator for this.
And we do this with opening
square brackets, one minus EQ,
one closing square brackets,
Echo dollar sign question mark.
This also shows us the same
return value exit code zero,
which means that the values do
equate, though this will throw
an error if you would use
alphabetical characters instead
of numerical ones.
Now for some more powerful
stuff, we can actually use these
test expressions and perform an
action on it. Let's have a look
at this more closely with an
actual script. Let's create a
login script which will not
really log us in but it will
show us what is possible with
these if Elif else statements.
Create a new script called if
Elif else.sh.
Type in the shebang.
Do F open the square brackets,
dollar sign, open curly braces,
one comma comma close curly
braces and I'll explain to you
what this means in just a second
equals your username, close the
square brackets, semicolon,
then, and then we follow up what
we actually want to do here. So
we want to echo Oh, you're the
boss here. Welcome.
Then start a new line. lf open
square brackets again, dollar
sign, curly braces, one comma
comma curly braces equals help.
Close the square brackets,
semicolon, then echo, just enter
your user name data. Else. Echo.
I don't know who you are, but
you're not the boss of me. And
then close it with FY. Now let
me explain to you what we did
here. So this script will take
in a positional argument, which
is a great way to test how the
if statements will work.
We start our if statements with
an F followed by the test
expression. Take note of the
square brackets used in previous
section, we test if the first
positional argument is equal to
the value we provide. Take note
of the double comma and the
curly braces. This is called a
parameter expansion. And it will
allow us to ignore upper and
lower cases when comparing the
two values. We then end the test
operator with a semicolon. And
we'll follow it up by then. And
then beginning a new line. And
on this line, we type what we
actually want to do with set
test expression. In this case,
we just print something out to
the console telling the user the
script has recognized the user
name and that he is indeed the
boss of the system. We can also
have a script check for multiple
test expressions. We can define
this with an elif statement.
This stands for else if being
that else if the previous
statement wasn't true test if
this is true. Again, start a new
line. We defined a test
expression that will test if the
positional argument is help. And
if it is, we display a message
that shows us instructions on
how to use the script. Being an
easy script we want to state
that it isn't so hard to use.
Maybe a little rude, but it's
all in good fun. Then if none of
these statements are true,
finally we have the else
statement. This will perform an
action if none of the if or Elif
statements are true. We can
display a message saying that
the user name was not detected
and that the system will not be
bossed around by someone that
does not have the correct
username.
Finally, to close our if
statements we ended with FYI.
This closes the entire block of
if Elif else statements and is
required.
If Elif else statements are
useful, but you won't use them
very often if you want to check
for multiple values. For these
kinds of things. We use case
statements. First of all, what
is a case statement? Well, a
case statement performs
different actions depending on
which case is true. This means
that we can define multiple
options, and if the option
matches the case, we will
perform an action bound to that
option. Let's have a look at how
this works in a real script.
Let's try to recreate our
previous exercise with a case
statement instead of the if Elif
else statements, create a new
file with vim login.sh and type
in the shebang. And then we
start our case statement by
typing in case space. Dollar
sign and then
ie variable expansion with the
curly brackets, one comma,
comma, space in and over here,
we're going to do something
special, we're going to define
multiple options. Now this is
something that you could also do
with if statements. But I'm just
introducing it here with the
case statements. Since I thought
it would be interesting to see
how it works. So we type in our
username, space, and then the
pipe symbol. And over here, this
is actually like a separator for
multiple options, rather than
the pipe symbol that we saw
earlier, to pipe things through
two different commands. In a
case statement, it serves a
different function over here, it
serves as a separator for
multiple options. So user name,
space, pipe, symbol, space, and
then another user name, for
example, the administrator, and
then we close the bracket. And
then we define what we want to
say or do here. So you want to
say something like, Oh, you're
the boss here, welcome, again,
like we did in the previous
exercise, and then we close this
option with double semicolons.
Then we define another option
here, for example, help like we
did in the previous exercise
will copy the same echo command
that we close that option with
double semi colons. And then
what we do here is we define
this star symbol or asterisk or
whatever you want to call it.
This is the catch all option
that we're going to define. And
the catch all option is like the
default option, when none of the
options are true, or when no
options are given. And then we
define Hello there, but you're
not the boss of me, please enter
a valid username, then we close
that option with double
semicolons. And then close that
with E sec. So it's case just
reversed. So again, like I said
before, notice that we have two
options in one line using the
pipe symbol, again, and when we
use the pipe symbol in one of
the case statement options, we
can use it to have multiple
values to test for, we define
our option for help. also define
a catch all or default option.
And this is equal to like the
else statement like we saw
earlier, meaning that if none of
the options are equal to the
input, we will perform a
specific action and now we can
run our scripts and get the
results that we expect.
Before we get into looping, we
need to first extend our
knowledge about variables, we
can actually assign multiple
values to one variable collected
in a list. We call these kinds
of variable lists arrays. Let's
see how we can actually create
this in the command line. In the
command line type my first list
equals open brackets one, space
two, space three, space four,
space five, close the brackets.
Take note of how we start the
array with open brackets, use a
space as a separator for each
item, and close the array with
the closing bracket. Now let's
see what the output is when we
try to print this array. Just
type in Echo, and then just like
we would with any other
variable, space, dollar sign my
first list and now we will see
that the output is just the
first element. And this is of
course not what we want. To echo
the entire list, we need to
specify it like this echo,
dollar sign, open curly braces,
my first list square brackets,
apt symbol, closing square
brackets, close the curly
braces, and this will print out
everything in the list. But we
can also define which item we
want to print like this echo
space, dollar sign curly braces,
my first list square brackets,
and then over here we'll just
type in zero, which is the
index, close the square brackets
close the curly braces, and this
will print out the first item in
the array because we define the
index in between the square
brackets. And because in bash,
the first item in the array
always has index zero counting
upwards we will see the first
item in the array. But let's say
we want to do something else
with all these items in the
array. We can do this with a for
loop.
Now that we have created our
array, we want to loop over the
items in it and do something
using a for loop. In our
example, we will count the
length of each word in the array
by piping the item output using
echo to the wc command
don't
Get to specify the minus n flag
in our echo command, because
otherwise it will also count the
newline characters.
type in the command line for
space, item space in dollar sign
curly braces, my first list,
square brackets at square
brackets, curly braces, semi
colon space, do space, echo
space minus n space, dollar sign
item, space pipe symbol SPACE,
wc space minus c semi colon
space done.
Take note of how we write the
for loop here, we first define
the variable item, which will
represent each item in the array
during the loop. Then we define
the iterable, which is our
array. And what shall we
actually define it in our for
loop, we encapsulate it in our
curly brackets and add the
square brackets, add square
brackets after it to make sure
we loop over the entire array.
Then we follow it up with a semi
colon space, then we type in do
and then we type in what we
actually want to perform here.
So we'll type in do echo minus
n. As I said the minus n is just
a flag for the echo command to
ignore all the newline
characters and then space dollar
sign item, because the dollar
sign item will represent one of
the items that we are currently
looping over space and then the
pipe symbol, WC minus c. And
then we do again semicolon, and
then we'd have been done.
To understand why we need
functions in a bash script, we
should first consider this. In
some scenarios, we have a lot of
repeated code, we might want to
do a specific set of commands in
a certain order. Or we want to
run that through a set of if
else statements multiple times.
For these scenarios, we create
functions. These functions are
like little programs within your
script that you can run from
within your script. It makes it
so that you can make your code
reusable very powerful stuff.
Because we can save so much time
and lines of code. Let's write
our first function in bash.
Let's open up a new file called
first function that sh i will
type in the shebang and then a
new line we'll type in the name
of the function and we'll just
call this show uptime. And then
we open and close the brackets.
And then we open the curly
brackets will type in up equals
dollar sign open brackets up
time minus p pipe cut minus C
for minus and then to close the
brackets. We'll type in since
equals dollar sign open brackets
uptime minus s, close the
brackets and again, if I'm going
a little bit too fast for you,
you can pause the video and I'm
gonna go over what we actually
did here, I'm going to dissect
everything we did here in just a
second. But then a new line
again cat and then we'll use the
double lesser than symbol elf, I
will type a new line I will just
create something pretty here. A
few dashes, I will type in this
machine has been up for dollar
sign curly braces up curly
braces, it has been running
since dollar sign curly brackets
since curly braces that a new
line of then we do a new line of
dashes. Then we end our
statement with elf, close the
curly brackets and then we just
type in show uptime. So let's
dissect this again. First, we
define the name of the function
followed by open and close
brackets followed by the curly
brackets. To define what our
function does, we enter all the
things that needs to do in
between the curly brackets. In
our case, we will show the
uptime of the machine. Watch how
he catched the output of a
command into a variable using
the dollar sign in brackets
notation, then we do this again
in the next variable. We defined
a variable in the same way. But
we use different flags for the
uptime command and store that
output in the since variable and
we can now create a nice output
using these variables using the
cat command and the redirection
we learned earlier in the course
we end by closing the curly
brackets, and then we call the
function by just typing it
anywhere in the script. As long
as it's typed under the function
it's fine, because we need to
make sure that the function
first is defined.
When we define a variable in our
function, it's available to the
entire script by default, this
might seem okay, but it can
actually cause trouble when you
write bigger scripts. We want to
define the variables inside our
functions as local variables so
that they are only available to
our function and not to the
entire script. This way, we will
avoid accidentally overwriting
global variables, which might
cause issues when we are using
functions that share these
variable names. Let's have a
look at what happens when we
don't use local variables. So
let's define our variables named
up equals
Before since equals function,
and then we'll just print those
out before we define the
function. So we'll just echo up
and echo since. And then now we
will define the show uptime
function. Again, we will leave
it the way it is, and then echo
up an echo since, and let's run
it and in this example, we can
see that the variables are
indeed globally available, which
is not what we wanted. We'll see
also that they are globally
available, but we have actually
overwritten the variables that
were defined before the
function. And then the function
was actually reassigning those
variables because they are not
assigned as local variables.
Let's fix that. So the only
thing we need to do to fix it
really is just add local before
we define the variable in our
function, so instead of just
writing up, and since equals the
commands that we want to use,
before the up, we'll just enter
local space. And then the same
goes for since we'll define
local space. And when we run
this, we can now see that our
variables are available to the
scope of our function, but the
global variable is not
overwritten.
Just like our entire bash script
can have a positional argument.
So can our function, let's have
a look at an example. Create a
new script called function pass
argue.sh. And we'll write the
shebang. And that will open our
function with the function name,
open the brackets, open the
curly brackets, and then we'll
write echo Hello, dollar sign
one.
And then close the curly
brackets. And then we'll write
the function name space. And
then whatever you want to write
here, we'll write our own name.
So we can write out whatever set
of characters we want. But in
this case, we wrote our own
name, we could even go as far as
to pass positional arguments of
the entire script to the
position or argument of the
function. And of course,
functions can also take multiple
positional arguments. So lots of
stuff is possible here.
Let's open up the previous file.
Underneath the echo statement,
we'll type an if statement. And
then we'll say if dollar sign
curly braces, one comma, comma
equals and then your user name,
which in my case is Herbert to
close the brackets semicolon,
then return zero, else, we will
return one. And that will close
the if statement. Then also over
here, we'll remove this static
name and change it to a
positional argument one, and
that also, if dollar sign
question mark equals one, then
close square brackets,
semicolon, then echo and then it
will write someone unknown
called the function and then
we'll close the if statements or
write and quit. And let's now
try to run this with tests. For
example. It'll say hello test,
but then you'll see that it also
says that someone unknown
requested the function.
Aw K is one of the most useful
tools in the bash arsenal, we
use aw K to filter file
contents, or the output of a
command in such a way that we
can print out the most essential
parts and get the output the way
we like it. So use aw K, we can
either filter parts of a file,
or we can filter parts of a
command output by piping that
output into a Wk let's have a
look at how we can filter
through a simple text file with
a Wk we first create a test file
which contains three words
separated by a space once we
created that file, we can put a
Wk to work type in a Wk single
quote, open the curly brackets
print dollar sign one, close
curly brackets, single quotes
space the name of our test file,
we will see that the dollar sign
one acts as a placeholder. For
the first item in the text file.
We could also get the second
word that comes after the first
word always separated by space
by typing in a Wk single quotes
curly braces, print dollar sign
to close curly braces single
quote and again our test file
now that we get the idea of aw K
in its default mode, which is
using a space character as a
separator, we can move on to
changing it into other
characters such as a car, let's
create a CSV file and add three
values in it again separated by
a comma this time now we can use
a Wk again to split the values
in the CSV file by adding the
minus capital F flag and
specifying the split character
afterwards like this aw k minus
capital F comma space open the
single quotes open the curly
braces print dollar sign one
close the curly braces single
quote test CSV dot CSV and now
we will see that the output is
also the same as in our previous
examples, but we will see that
aw K actually used the comma as
a separator character. And last
but not least, we can also pipe
commands into a Wk like so type
in Echo just get this word colon
hello and then we pipe into a Wk
I will
print out number five, because
this is the fifth word separated
by a space and then we'll see
that the word hello will be
printed out. Or we can also
split this at the colon symbol
like so. Echo, just get this
word colon Hello, pipe into a
WK. And then we specify the
minus f, we follow it up with a
colon and then print dollar sign
to and that will still have to
cut out the first character
which is a space and that will
get the same results as well.
And that's just the beginning.
Of course, there's a lot more
possible with a WK. So if you
want to practice you can try
using it more often in your
scripts. It really pays off to
know this well because you'll do
a lot of output filtering and
reformatting in bash.
There will come a time where you
want to change certain values in
text files, and that's where sed
or set comes in. Set is a
command line tool that will
allow you to modify values in a
txt file using regular
expressions. Let's have a look
at an example on how to use as
Edie are set to replace values
in a text file. Create a text
file called Set test dot txt and
let's write down some text here.
Now we will replace the word fly
with grasshopper just for
demonstration purposes. So we
type in set single quotes s
forward slash fly forward slash
grasshopper forward slash G
single quotes and then the name
of our txt file, which is set
test dot txt. Now the structure
of this command is a little bit
daunting, but let's break it
down. First, we start off with
the set command, we open the
single quotes and start our
regular expression. First we
enter the mode we want to use,
which is as for substitute,
meaning we want to substitute
the next word behind the forward
slash with the word after the
second forward slash, which is
the first one is fly. And then
the second one is grasshopper
that after the last, we provide
the G which means that we want
to do this globally. G stands
for globally and globally means
that we want to do this across
the entire text file, which
means that we want to change
every occurrence, we close it
with another single quote and we
put the text file we want to
change behind the entire
command. Let's say we want to
keep the original in a backup
file. We can do this by adding
the minus II flag to the command
like so. So we just do the same
thing we just do set minus i dot
original and then we enter the
exact same command we just
provided earlier, we can see
here that we use the minus II
flag, but we don't put a space
behind it. Instead, we write the
entire suffix behind the minus
II flag. This will create a
backup file which contains the
original content of the file we
just changed with the set
command but the original file
will have the changes we desired
just like with aw k this is a
basic introduction to set and
there will be so much more to it
but as with all things in it,
you need to discover this by
yourself by trying it out as
much as you can. Well this
brings us to the end of the
course